[Musique]
quelle agriculture demain en
franche-comté dimanche en politique
ouvre le débat ce matin bonjour à tous
soyez les bienvenus
nous sommes avec trois candidats aux
chambres d'agriculture les agriculteurs
qui ont jusqu'à jeudi de la semaine
prochaine pour voter par courrier ou par
internet
alors cette campagne peut-elle changer
le visage de nos campagnes comment nos
agriculteurs vont ils remonter la pente
eux qui se plaignent régulièrement de ne
pas vivre décemment de leur travail
comment redorer le blason de cette
profession souvent pointé du doigt
notamment pour son impact sur
l'environnement on va en débattre avec
nos invités je vous les présente tout de
suite d'abord daniel prieur président de
la chambre d'agriculture du doubs et du
territoire de belfort vous êtes candidat
fdsea dans le département du doubs
également sur ce plateau élise grossiord
candidate vous de la confédération
paysanne dans le département du jura est
à vos côtés daniel pepiot candidat de la
coordination rurale dans le département
du doubs bonjour à tous les trois merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors comme chaque semaine vous le savez
vous aussi devant votre télévision vous
pouvez participer à cette émission
réagir commentée sur les réseaux sociaux
grâce aux mots diez qui s'affiche dit
mme paul fc comme dimanche en politique
franche comté je me ferai le relais de
vos questions de vos interpellations
tout au long de ce débat alors madame
messieurs
d'abord pour que les téléspectateurs
comprennent bien les enjeux de ce
scrutin
pouvez vous nous expliquer à quoi sert
une chambre d'agriculture ont commencé
avec vous daniel prieur chambre
d'agriculture c'est la représentation de
l'agriculture officielle auprès du
préfet auprès des conseillers
départementaux et pour ce qui est du
niveau régional auprès des préfets des
régions et du privé du délai du conseil
régional
ça c'est sur l'aspect je dirais très
officiel la voix des agriculteurs
alors la loi des agriculteurs est né à
la fois celle amenée par les gens mais
celle aussi à
et par les organisations
professionnelles et notamment les
organisations syndicales après dans le
fonctionnement de la chambre
il y a les aspects qui sont liés à
l'accompagnement de l'agriculteur tout
au long de sa vie que ça soit pour ce
qui est du domaine de l'installation des
jeunes du développement des aménagements
qu'il a à faire dans son exploitation
et puis quelque part de préparer sa
succession et donc ça sa transmission de
l'outil et puis on a quand même une
marge de liberté
il marche de liberté de travail et moi
je sais que dans la chambre a dit
d'agriculture du doubs territoire de
méforme
on était dépositaire et propose un
certain nombre de projets qui vont de
l'impact dans des filières avec bien sûr
knows how s'ils font tout ce qu'ils sont
un élément enfants mais aussi d'aider
dans des domaines plus sociétaux avec
notamment tous les enjeux
environnementaux vous ont pas lire en
préambule de l'énergie avec les aspects
liés à la qualité de l'eau ellis
grossiord vous êtes élue d'opposition
dans le département du jura
la chambre d'agriculture ses élus ils
ont un impact sur la vie quotidienne des
agriculteurs oui parce que c'est aussi
un prestataire de services donc la
chambre dans l'activité de conseil on va
dire oui voilà la validité de conseils
par exemple pour faire les appels les
plans film c'est
tous les déclarations que les
agriculteurs font surtout ce qu'ils
dépendent sur leur leurs chants donc on
peut demander à la chambre d'agriculture
de faire ça du conseil sur tout un tas
de choses
donc oui c'est si les couleurs
politiques ou syndicales de l'élu elle
change quoi dans ces cas là des élus
qu'on a à la chambre
les politiques sont différentes ben oui
bien sûr enfin on n'a pas du tout la
même vision de de l'agriculture oui mais
du coup c'est un impact la couleur des
élus peut avoir un impact sur le sur
l'agriculture du département concerné
disons que les syndicats minoritaires on
est très peu représentée à la chambre
donc on a très peu d'impact en fait
daniel pepiot il vous est dans le même
cas de figure
oui tout à fait c'est ça qu'on peut dire
c'est que on est juste or on est juste
des observateurs on est juste à
comprendre le comment fonctionne la
jambe mais on a pas on être minoritaire
c'est vrai que on représente une bonne
porte
quand même en pourcentage on n'est pas
si bon que ça puisqu'on se tient au même
pourcentage mais quand on se trouve à la
chambre on se retrouve à deux donc
ensuite c'est plus là c'est pas c'est
pas la politique qu'on a envie de mener
qui peut être prise alors justement on
va voir la composition des chambres
comtoise qu'on a cumulé vous allez voir
la fnsea où les fds sont quasiment réglé
les jeunes agriculteurs qui quasiment
hégémonique
vous allez voir sur les quatre
départements donc vous l'avais dit il ya
une seule chambre pour les deux
départements du doubs et du territoire
de belfort ya 49 élus fdsea
jia donc fédération départementale d
syndicats d'exploitants agricoles et
jeunes agriculteurs six élus pour la
confédération paysanne six élus pour la
coordination rurale
je vais me faire volontairement
provocateur daniel prieur l'agriculture
smart ou l'agriculture va mal vous avez
tous les pouvoirs ou presque
est ce que c'est un peu de votre faute
si vous voudrez pour sa fille m'a dit
vous l'aurez pas non je pense que c'est
un peu plus compliqué que ça on gère les
chambres d'agriculture les chambres
d'agriculture n'ont pas le pouvoir sur
monsieur biya si monsieur lactalis ou
sur la vie de ce héros grands patrons
des groupes qui achètent notamment du
lait oui mais on est en franche comté
on va parler de franche comté à la
franche comté en franche comté on a géré
deux types d'organisations de
l'agriculture
on est une agrégation d'agriculture qui
est donc très localisés avec donc le
système qu'on connait bien avec les
fruitières avec une dimension
territoriale de l'agriculture avec des
gens qui ne vous qui ne vont pas un
minerai qu'est le lait mais qui vendent
un fromage et nous trois on fait partie
de cette ce type d'agriculture on peut
quand même pas pleurer quand on a dû les
à 520 euros voire 550 euros la tonne sur
ce territoire
et puis moi qui fais la campagne
nationale que je vois des gens qui sont
en peine à 300
donc qu'est le cas par exemple pour ses
quinze exploitations de l'audition de
ces lampes ou ya pas de lui mais en au
conflit ou quand on veut dire que la
politique qui est menée n'est pas une
bonne politique parce que j'ai senti
mais ce qu'ils ont dit et l'un et
l'autre on va y revenir
recentré sa me fait pas sourire mais
sans faire réfléchir et à penser à ce
qu'on a vécu quand on a notamment
développé un certain nombre de choses
moi dans la chambre que je connais qui
est celle que je prie vide autour de
l'évolution vers
l'agriculture biologique autour du lait
sans ogm autour de l'auto
approvisionnement protéines plutôt
d'aller l'acheter en amérique du sud
bon je sais pas pour leur demander on va
leur demander
elisa est ce qu'ils auraient eu la même
niaque que celle que j'ai eue par
rapport à ces dynamiques thouars et lise
gros sur la fdsea et notamment la
chambre du doubs et vertueuse en termes
d'impact environnemental développement
du bio voilà moi je connais pas
particulièrement la chambre du doubs je
vais me contenter de ce que je connais
un mais enfin je pense pas que la
chambre d'agriculture du est vraiment
fait se développer la bio enfin je veux
dire pour moi c'est pas ça vient pas de
là enfin je veux dire interbio les gab
se sont mis en oeuvre à promouvoir
l'agriculture biologique
parce que les chambres ne le faisait pas
avec la chambre sont ce qui nous
concerne
ça c'est pas fait contre la chambre ça
c'était avec la chambre va demander le
respect qu il connaît bien le il est élu
dans le doubs lui
oui mais moi je trouve qu'on parle d'eux
on veut tout mettre sur la chambre mais
je trouve que la chambre elle a un
impact quand même limité parce qu'elle
est la compagne
moi je suis d'accord c'est là qu'elle à
chambéry culture accompagne les
agriculteurs pour leur installation
comme cadet pour certaines démarches
qu'on a à faire sur l'installation autre
chose après c'est pas la chambre
d'agriculture qui va résonner sur
l'agriculture aujourd'hui si on parle
aujourd'hui que l'agriculture a du mal
d'aller c'est bien des problèmes de prix
c'est bien
enfin la coupe des nations est toujours
naturelle vous disiez tout à l'heure on
est minoritaire
on n'arrive pas à faire passer nos idées
la grande question c'est comment les
agriculteurs peuvent vivre enfin de leur
travail finalement vous quelles sont vos
idées quelle est votre vision de
l'agriculture et qu'est ce que vous
feriez si vous étiez aux commandes d'une
chambre
ce jeu peut prêter que si les nôtres un
décor est donc pratiquement tous les
départements aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils
cherchent à progresser et c'est vrai que
pour venir pour venir majoritaire ont
rappelé comme ça ou aux consoles et côté
il faut qu'on prenne des chambres
ensuite les chambres et à leur
fonctionnement
ils ont dû accompagner les agriculteurs
mais c'est ensuite être avoir du poids
devant des députés devant devant le
gouvernement pour pouvoir dire il faut
changer de politique convaincant mais
donc vous changer quoi mais il faut déjà
prendre le prendre apple power pour
pouvoir qu'on nous écoute un peu plus
vous allez prendre beaucoup de risques
parce que vous ferez quand vous à bâtir
canton l'horreur on cherchera à avoir
des prix rémunérateurs à avoir je parle
on parlait tout juste entendu parler de
ce genre je sais par exemple que nous
n'est pas d'accord de voir des arrivages
de soja avec des résidus de glyphosate
qui sont très importants et puis qui
sont arrivés en france
et puis ensuite on est
voilà qu'on nous dit qu'il ya des
claques et culture pollue mais dans le
même moment enfin la coordination avait
fait des prélèvements des échantillons
de ces les sojas et puis el hafed en
même temps des échantillons de produits
français qui utilisent bien sûr des
livres aux actes et là pas de résidus
donc on ne doit pas laisser entrer ces
marchandises là on a du blé mais ça
ukrainien qui arrive à cause de laquelle
vous êtes tous les trois d'accord
comment est-ce que c'est pas une
question sur lequel sur laquelle vous
êtes tous les trois d'accord finalement
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas pour
qu'on l'est parce que les entrées tout
ça donc on doit pouvoir faire on a
milité on a interrogé énormément le
président de la république énormément
les députés en dix ans
faisons attention à ce qu'on veut sur
notre agriculture et que tu roules avait
dit aujourd'hui elle est dans le débat
public
c'est un c'est une question de société
dans le même temps on a toute une
kyrielle d'interdiction qui arrive sur
un certain nombre de produits qui
peuvent être totalement justifiée mais
attention à ce qu'on interdise les
produits chez nous et quand même temps
où les uns portent systématiquement avec
des choses qui viennent de l'extérieur
je suis d'accord avec ce qu'a dit daniel
par rapport à ces fameux résidus de
niveau 1 qui peuvent arriver mais bon on
est presque à l'heure du repas là avec
cette émission ce dimanche ce qui est
hyper important à dire c'est que
l'aspect vertueux de l'agriculture il se
fera si la chambre d'agriculture qui met
ces aspect vertueux en avant dans les
aspects du coup seuil aux agriculteurs
et mais s'il ya aussi des filières
derrière qui sont capables de bien
valoriser ces aspect vertueux gagner le
priant on parle du glyphosate le
président de la république a dit
vendredi que finalement on n'arriverait
pas supprimer les usages
du glyphosate à 100% comme il l'avait
promis d'ici trois ans et c'est une
bonne ou une mauvaise décision selon moi
je sais pas si c'est une bonne ou une
mauvaise décision
c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt la
fnsea s'est beaucoup battu pour
repousser la date irex bien par
n'importe quoi s'il vous plaît la fnsea
elle a travaillé sur un projet qui
s'appelle un contrat de solutions oui ce
contrat de solutions que certains
appellent contrat de soumission c'est
l'objectif de ramener aux agriculteurs
des solutions pour pouvoir se séparer
d'un certain nombre de matières art et
donc d'allonger la période de
conservatisme s'il vous plaît chez moi
on est sur une logique d'évolution
d'agriculture arrête la société ondemand
nous à pouvoir avoir des solutions parce
que on peut derrière une table
c'est très facile dire que demain on
peut sortir totalement du nucléaire
sortir totalement du diesel sortir aussi
du lit faisable puisque ces dix 3-1
mammouth que l'ont amené dans les
questions de société
moi ce qui m'importe c'est que demain
les pays d'horizon des solutions sur
leur exploitation et c'est comme ça
qu'on a travaillé à les finisseurs ellis
grossir ils ont des solutions ou pas
pour pallier une suppression d'une
interdiction du glyphosate les
agriculteurs des techniques voilà qui
existent puisque les agriculteurs qui
sont en bien failli à des agriculteurs
qui se passe du lift hosatte ce qu'il
faut c'est accompagner les paysans qui
l'utilisent à s'en passer
nous on n'est pas enfin on dit pas qu'il
faut sortir demain tout de suite
ce qu'il faut c'est que non non non je
ne mène à non absolument pas c'est parce
qu'on arrive enfin micron pas du tout je
pense que là dessus on est claire je
pense que est évidemment qu'on peut pas
sortir demain il faut se mettre des
échéances mais il faut accompagner les
paysans et je pense pas que
la position de la conf ce soit de dire
demain plus personne n'utilise rien
effectivement il faut sortir du
glyphosate et puis en compte et de
glyphosate enfin la destruction des
prairies si migros - été fait et ils
sont très bons les choix je suis je suis
d'accord sur certains points vont couper
la parole là mais l'interdiction la
destruction chimique des prairies est
une très bonne décision
alors nous on allait plus loin en disant
qu'il fallait interdire le glyphosate
dans les céréales qu'ont donnés aux
animaux et se serait tiré la filière
vers le haut que d'arriver à avoir des
céréales qui viennent d'inde de la
grande région et qu'ils soient produits
sans glyphosate et lise gros science
j'aimerais revenir à la question de
départ comment faire pour qu'aujourd'hui
les agriculteurs vivent de leur travail
et vivent décemment puisque beaucoup n'y
arrive pas alors nous on défend un
projet que qui s'appelle l'agriculture
paysanne et nous notre projet c'est
remettre le paysan au centre et créer de
l'emploi
c'est à dire quoi remettre le paysan au
centre il n'est pas aujourd'hui
bah non pas forcément
enfin je veux dire quand on a des délits
ferme qui deviennent des fermes immense
et que finalement le paysan il est
beaucoup obligés de s'équiper de alors
que il ya plein de d'équipement
d'ailleurs l'utilisation des pesticides
du glyphosate
pourquoi on a commencé à utiliser ça
c'est aussi parce que le nombre de
d'actifs dans les fermes a diminué
donc il ya énormément d'emplois a recréé
en agriculture pour pallier aussi
à ces problèmes daniel pepiot sur cette
question nous n'est pas on soutient
toutes les fermes c'est à dire que c'est
l'agriculture elle est elle est là
aujourd'hui on va pas de tour modifié
quand une petite ferme peut gagner sa
vie je pense que c'est très très bien
après les agricultures a évolué et du
matériel qui a évolué donc on peut pas
non plus dire forcément qu une grosse
exploitation va plus pollués après on a
profité pendant des années des nouveaux
produits et ce qu'on disait il ya
arriver rires parce qu'il n'ya pas ce
qu'il faisait at il ya beaucoup d'autres
produits d'herbicides de faux logiciels
tout ce qu'on a utilisé c'était autorisé
c'est ça qui est quand même qui nous
fait mal c'est que c'est tous des
produits qui était qui avaient des mises
sur dix autorisations de mise sur le
marché
aujourd'hui on nous dit qu'ils polluent
alors il fallait les arrêter avant
après c'est vrai que c'était une
facilité pour l'agriculture on en a
profité et c'était plus facile que parce
que les bio ils ont c'est pas tout
simple de pouvoir travailler des
céréales 104 chardon sont que trop de
mauvaises herbes
il faut faire travailler un peu par
l'ancien mais pour prendre des anciennes
techniques qui ont pourtant bien bien
travaillé longtemps bien existé mais
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise chose
pour vous 2 de revenir travailler à
l'ancienne sans forcément les produits
si vite c'est à dire que les produits
chimiques on va quand même compris qu'il
y en avait quand même bien assez on a
trop utiliser donc il faut bien changer
de technique
las assure daniel prieur oui moi ce que
j'aimerais aussi qu'on aborde parce que
là on en a parlé d' ugly faut on a parlé
type d'agriculture
je pense qu'il faut pas oublier le rôle
très important des jeunes et notamment
de l'installation en franche comté
on est une des régions de france qui est
la plus dynamique en matière
d'installation et si elle est limpide il
m'a dit dynamique en matière
d'installation
c'est parce que on à moi je souris pas
parce que c'est la réalité
malheureusement c'est parce que on a lu
un souci un moment donné chez les jeunes
agriculteurs de favoriser le
renouvellement des générations avec un
programme d'installation
régional mais aussi un vrai
accompagnement de l'installation avec
des filières qui sont rémunératrices
quand
wahou aujourd'hui dans les comices
agricoles dans un crs vous parlez pas et
c'est ce que vous pensez à tout ce qu'il
ya en dehors de la zone comptait pas ce
qu'il fait et fit l'enfance la zone
compte et dynamique parce qu'il ya des
prix rémunérateurs mais aimer tous les
autres et d'ailleurs les manifestations
d'agriculteurs
elles ont toujours été plus virulente en
haute saône où la situation est plus
compliquée par exemple ag je pense
énormément aux autres aux autres
territoires et dans les autres
territoires
on voit qu'il ya des gens qui sont sur
des recherches de solutions la haute
saône est un des départements cas le
plus de pourcentage de ses terres en
agriculture biologique
c'est bien un accompagnement pour aller
vers plus de valeur ajoutée
les agriculteurs de haute saône sous
l'impulsion de leur organisation
syndicale est venue à jeunes
agriculteurs viennent de monter un
magasin pour vendre directement le
produit au coeur de vesoul sait bien des
démarches qui sont pour aller vers plus
de valeur ajoutée et donc plus devenu et
continuer d'attirer les jeunes dans
l'agriculture les océans vous vous
sembliez douter sur non pas du tout non
non non c'est juste que
on me dit quelques mots en aparté c'est
pour ça que souriez pas sûr alors
dites-moi sur le sur cette dynamique là
alors moi je félicite vraiment mais
sincèrement la fdsea de gironde de haute
saône pour l'ouverture de ce magasin de
producteurs
mais enfin nous ça fait longtemps que
l'on dit qu' il faut faire ça et mais je
suis sincèrement très contente que eh
bien aujourd'hui vous faites des choses
comme ça il ya une tendance et alors
vous en avez parler les uns les autres
voilà c'est effectivement le bio l'étude
qui est parue cette semaine qui montre
que la franche comté est en avance par
rapport à la moyenne nationale puisqu'on
doit être un peu plus autour de 9% de
l'assurance qu'on appelle la surface
agricole utile qui est en bio
aujourd'hui il ya le bio il ya les
circuits courts
est ce que finalement il faut tendre
davantage versa est ce que faut pas
changer de modèle parce que vous parliez
tout à l'heure de lactalis ou des grands
groupes laitiers qui
avec lesquels finalement les
agriculteurs sont souvent pieds et
poings liés puisque le décide pas du
prix auquel ils vont vendre leur
production
est ce que finalement la solution elle
n'est pas vers ces filières là oui bien
sûr je pense que il faut tendre là pour
avoir plus de valeur ajoutée et puis
redonner du sens au métier de paysan je
pense que c'est ça la solution
daniel pepiot on peut augmenter
indéfiniment le taux de surface e.on en
agriculture bio je suis par contre du
tout ça sûrement c'est sûrement bon mais
moi j'ai quand même se doute de la
grande distribution et puis je reviens
toujours donc premier slogan c'était des
prix pas des primes
donc les biens des prix rémunérateurs
qu'on demande depuis c'est comme ça le
vrai problème de franche comté
parce qu'on a beau nous avoir notre
compte et j'ai dit a pas très longtemps
que le comté et peut-être mais dans le
comté on voit aussi de la viande rossi
du port où vent et puis là puis a pas
que le port en franche comté il n'y a
pas que le que le comté en franche comté
donc on veut bien il faut bien partir
sur le bio poursuivre le consommateur
mais il faut que l'agriculteur soient
conscients de ça aussi mais ce que j'ai
peur quand même c'est la grande
distribution c'est que ils sont forts
aussi ici ils ont toujours tenu les cris
bord dont les autres produits ils sont
capables aussi parce qu' on voit bien à
quel point ils sont là quand on a des
petits mots raisin comme biocoop ya d
autres d autres circuits de produits bio
qui sont qui sont peu dire comme
démarche équitable qui savent respecter
les producteurs là on peut aller l'homme
et quand on part à la grande
distribution comme on voit leurs crayons
aujourd'hui de deux bios g15 doute là
donc ça pour ça qu'on doit toujours
avoir des contrats il semblait qu avec
eux le projet qui devait y avoir avec
monsieur macron puisqu'il ya eu ce
problème
blasé de même pris et qu'il faut que
l'on arrive à tenir ça parce
qu'autrement on fasse du bio coface
autre chose on sera toujours avoir du
mal à vivre de notre métier
daniel prieur c'est possible de se
libérer les grands groupes alors des
grands groupes aujourd'hui c'est à peu
près 80 % à 90 % de l'alimentation ça
dépend les les types de l'équipe 2 des
types de produits les grands groupes qui
vont à la pêche 1 ils vont à la pêche
aux consommateurs ils ont des grands
filets pour prendre la majorité des
consommateurs
ils ont mis un petit filet d'un côté
pour prendre les gens qui sont
consommateurs bio et puis un autre de
l'autre côté pour prendre les gens qui
sont consommateurs de produits locaux
moi ce que je constate c'est qu'il faut
que l'on fasse pas que dire mais que
l'on fasse les choses et on salue
l'initiative de au sol mais moi il ya
d'autres choses que j'aimerais pouvoir
dire sur 6 a touché encore émission ces
accrocs choquant c'est ce qu'on a pu
faire à belfort notamment redéveloppant
lui un travail autour du munster famille
alors qu'elle est plus de production de
munster sur le territoire de belles
nouveau de nouvelles installations de le
producteur de m'installer jean marie a
été en lait conventionnel qui ont fait
le choix de transformer et d'amener une
valeur ajoutée et ça c'est pas dire et
l'idée de tel ou tel syndicat
c'est le travail de la chambre avec des
gens qui sont en responsabilité
on a des questions j'en ai trois là sous
les yeux de j'aurais pas le temps de
déposer tout mais sur le
la cohabitation entre les bio et le
conventionnel et je vous en ligne par
exemple c'est tanguy
il nous dit installé en apiculture bio
dans le doubs il n'y a pas de volonté de
favoriser la préservation de nos
abeilles
pire les instances ne sont pas du tout
en faveur de l'apiculture biologique
c'est à l'apiculteur de lutter pour
trouver des zones saines de butinage
alors que ce devrait être aux pollueurs
d'avoir des mesures de protection qui
veut répondre monsieur pepiot vous êtes
d'accord avec ce constat où vous vous
inscrivez en faut c'est un peu compliqué
parce que je vois que il faut que c'est
sûr qu'il faut être dans un secteur où
il ya du bio pour pouvoir mettre des
abeilles mais vous quelqu'un qui veut
s'installer en abbaye bio dans un
secteur enfin moi je trouve que l'on va
loin je crois qu'il faut qu'à moi aussi
respecter est l'hôte agriculture parce
qu'on croit que yakin bio qui est bon et
puis on a beaucoup de produits surtout
en plus d'un autre région du doubs jura
on a est de montagne en ont quand même
qu'on est déjà tout ça que du contest
tous savaient que de l'herbe
il faut il faut arrêter aussi de croire
qu'on va faire que du miel bio
scootériste grossir rapidement c'est
très compliqué la cohabitation entre les
bio et le conventionnel alors je dirais
moi de ce que je connais non parce que
ça peut bien se passer a pu bien se
passer aussi
mais dans ce sera oui pardon mais par
rapport aux abeilles je dirais que c'est
compliqué parce que les abeilles elles
sont très sensibles
e toutes les matières chimiques c'est
pour ça que la cohabitation 6 à tous les
trois c'est déjà la fin on aurait pu
faire beaucoup plus long je suis désolé
je vous souhaite à tous les trois une
bonne femme campagne et puis voilà le on
suivra évidemment les élections aux
chambres d'agriculture sur france3 bon
dimanche à tous